i consume a lot of stuff between
physical books and audiobooks and kindle
books and podcasts newsletters online
articles tweets online courses i am
constantly surrounded by information
that ranges from completely
life-changing to very annoyingly i'm not
sure if i'll ever need this but i don't
want to let it go and
it's very difficult to manage and
process all of these things in the good
old days before i had any sort of
electronic devices or internet what i
used to do is just write in the margins
of my books and i had little notepads
where i would take particularly
interesting information but with the
sheer quantity and sources of what i am
reading right now that has become
completely impossible and most
importantly inefficient
so
a few thousand pounds of online
note-taking courses later and between
one and two personal decades of taking
notes from books in general i have come
up with quite a few different principles
systems and ways to effectively capture
notes from everything so i take this a
bit overboard with things like my second
brain if you want to check that out
there's a video somewhere but the first
step of that capture i think is
something that is important for
basically everyone if you want to trust
something other than your short-term
memory with something that you have read
that is a capture system and today i'm
going to show how i take all of these
sources that i mentioned and put them
all together in one place so i have just
two notion pages for literally
everything so all these resources just
come to notion and that is all that i do
so if this sounds interesting i'll be
going through it in this video the first
thing i'm going to be talking about are
my principles of capture just because
this is such a huge topic and i have
some personal
kind of rules for how i approach note
taking in general but if this is kind of
too theoretical for you you can skip
ahead i'll be talking about digital
books audiobooks physical books online
articles and tweets in this videos you
can skip ahead to any segment that you
prefer instead so let's get started with
the fun theory which are my five
personal principles of capture i have my
computer in front of me let's get
started with all of them so number one
it needs to be as frictionless as
possible i am renowned for being on my
phone without having slept yet at 3 30
or 4 am just scrolling through twitter
and this is not the time where i am
going to be going through a full article
or deciding on what's important or not
so i need whatever sort of system i have
to be super super easy where i can take
anything i want and send it to where i
want it to be within preferably less
than two seconds i think that is kind of
the range of patients that i have for
these sort of things it needs to be
frictionless because i need to be able
to do it from anywhere on any device and
i don't want to lose out on potentially
valuable information that i don't have
the patience attention or time to get my
second principle is that all this
information needs to be siloed into as
few places as possible if i have all the
information that i capture kind of
spread among 10 000 different apps and
different sort of systems it's kind of
pointless i've done this in the past i
used to have it in separate notebooks
for example or i tried a few different
ios apps and they're all great for their
separate purposes but the issue is
everything just remains separate and
everywhere and in the end of the day i
have to do so much work to find what i
need and most importantly 99 of things
i'll completely forget that i ever
captured so i've come to the point where
literally everything that i ever see or
read goes into two nursing pages and
that is kind of the system that i prefer
and the best way that things are done
for me but whatever kind of final
destination that you have i would
recommend having one ideally or just a
few final destinations for on all the
information that you capture so it
always can be just one quick search away
number three is that whatever system of
capture that i have needs to have levels
of processing and what i mean by this is
that for example i'll get something that
i think might be important but i haven't
read it and i might approach it later
and realize this is completely pointless
and in the same way there'll be a few
gems within that so i would need to have
a system where i can delete the things
that i find are not valuable and keep
the things i find are incredibly
valuable so
not everything has the same level of
importance and there needs to be a few
steps here that i can take something
farther into being very very important
and more important more important and
kind of like keep promoting information
and also be able to keep demoting
information based on how relevant or
valuable or important it is for me these
filters do not have to be immediate
sometimes i will filter through things
about six months or even a year after
i've first captured them but the main
thing is that i can sleep peacefully at
night because i know that they are
somewhere safe number four is that
everything needs to have resources no
matter where i capture things from i
need to know who said this what book did
they say it and for example what study
did it come from what web page did it
come from because it's kind of rude to
mention other people's things without
mentioning the resource so i do try to
keep kind of the backtrack of where
things come from and sometimes very very
fortunately these things are just done
automatically but it's just something
that i keep in mind if i'm taking
physical notes or things elsewhere that
are not done with kind of the internet
backlog and number five and i think this
is the most important one is that all of
my captures need to have a why whenever
i capture something it is always because
i'm finding it interesting at the moment
but i am always a different person even
within you know half an hour i will
become a different person it's the kind
of context that i have in my mind which
can be emotional which can be based on
the things that i've been reading that
day or that week or that month which
primes my mind in such a way that when
i'm consuming something and finding it
interesting it is for a specific reason
that is very unlikely to come up again
and again so if i see something
sometimes even one day later but even
worse if it's something that i captured
three years ago i have no idea why i
found this interesting what i thought i
was going to use this for so i have this
very strict rule in my mind that
whenever i capture something and i try
to stick to this most of the time
whenever i capture something this might
be a small highlight in a book or it
might be a full article or a full
youtube video i will always write why i
thought this was interesting and what i
thought i could use this for because
without these two bits of context i can
never snap right back to what i was
thinking easily and it just becomes a
piece of information which i might as
well have left on the internet because
even like searching for it on a youtube
webpage and searching for it in my notes
will just yield the same thing i have no
clue it's not personalized to me and i
don't know what it's about so i think
this fifth principle of capture is the
most important in my opinion if you want
to make any sort of changes to your
capture system the first thing i would
do is just write your whys why did you
find this interesting why did you want
to capture it so firstly let's talk
about digital books and these are by far
the easiest thing to kind of capture
from i usually read digital books on
apple books or recently i've bought a
kindle and i use a kindle um but these
are the two places where i will be
reading digital books in general what i
use for these is an app called read wise
it's honestly like having a little
personal assistant which just sorts out
all your information for you so what it
does is that it connects to kindle and
then it also connects to apple books and
it takes everything for me and puts it
into a notion personal library so as i'm
making highlights in my book and as i'm
making notes in my book for those
highlights they all get automatically
put into a kind of page on notion which
has the book title and the book
information inside and all of my notes
all of my highlights will be there and
these automatically keep refreshed and
keep uploaded so every time that i am
reading a book all i have to do is treat
it in the same way that i used to treat
a physical book before where i just
write in the margins which is the
equivalent of note taking in the book
and underlying things which is the
equivalent of kind of highlighting and
everything automatically goes and gets
saved onto my notion page and i have a
full library there which i'm building
unfortunately device is quite new for me
because until very recently i didn't
feel as though i could afford it but
it's honestly been the most
life-changing thing for digital book
capture now if you are still in the boat
and you cannot afford something like
read-wise what i used to do in the past
is for example any sort of app like
apple books will allow you to export all
of your highlights in one place so you
can see them one by one on the app but
if you go to export it will allow you to
send these in an email to yourself so
you'll get an email with all of your
highlights and notes in one place i
would copy all of this thing and put
that into a notion library of my own so
it takes a few extra minutes and it's
not automatic but definitely if you
don't want to spend the money you can do
this the same thing is applicable for
most sort of apps where you can read
things on number two is audiobooks and
this is where things start getting a bit
difficult when i first started listening
to audiobooks i got so frustrated when i
realized that they don't give you the
physical book automatically i thought i
just think that would be such a good
idea to just get both of them together
because then it becomes so much easier
to take notes but i'm sure there's very
good reasons why this is not being done
but basically the way that i take notes
on audiobooks depends on how amazing the
audiobook is so for example i started
reading 101 essays which will change the
way that you think a few days ago and
within literally a few paragraphs i
thought oh no this is not an audio book
this will have to be a physical book
because it is so so good i have so many
notes to take on this so what i did then
is i kind of bought the physical book
version of it or you can download the
lexical book version of it and i will
listen to the audiobook while i am also
reading it on my kindle or on my
computer and then i will just highlight
it as i'm listening to it at the same
time so then it turns into a physical
book and i am using the way that i
described earlier or if the book is not
that great and i'm sorry um or if
there's just not that many highlights to
take what i will do is as i'm listening
to the audiobook i probably have my
phone next to me because i'll have
headphones on and i'm listening from my
iphone what i do is i just go to my
apple notes app it's actually one of my
favorite apps of all time it's so easy
and quick and efficient and it loads a
lot faster on my phone that notion does
so i'll just take notes as i'm listening
and these will generally not be quotes
word for word unless there is something
that is needs to be very specific when
i'll actually pause what i'm listening
to and type the thing out but what i'll
generally do is just write the main gist
of what i'm finding interesting or the
main learning points of what is kind of
transforming me while i'm reading this
book and i'll create a note of it and
once i'm done with the book i will just
copy and paste this into notion i don't
find this to be too tiresome i'm used to
doing this all the time and um yes if
you ever see me out and about in london
kind of texting on my phone there's a 7
out of 10 chance that i'm actually
taking notes of a book that i'm
listening to than texting someone so a
lot of my typing on my iphone is
actually me taking book notes rather
than anything else that's how i take
notes of audio books and next everything
onto physical books i have such a strong
love-hate relationship with physical
books because i think reading a physical
book and taking notes in it and kind of
underlining things there is no more
therapeutic of an activity for me than
doing that however when it comes to
collecting my notes and processing notes
it is so painful to do it that way that
i just don't know how to balance it but
because i've had to move around so much
i've kind of decided to not allow myself
to buy physical books anymore so i've
kind of circumvented this problem but
sometimes especially philosophy books i
just i buy them physically because they
are so so much fun to use so what i do
for physical books is what i used to do
in the past which is kind of underline
them and create notes on the margins
until my early 20s i used to actually
treat books as they as though they were
made of gold and never write in them but
now i just like fall down the pages and
i yeah don't care as much so um i will
kind of take notes wherever they are
imported in a book if i'm taking
particularly a lot of notes on a page
i'll literally fall down the edge of the
page and just go through the book that
way and in the end there are two ways i
would recommend taking notes from
physical books the first thing i will do
is i will then download the online copy
of the book and as i will open that in
usually my apple books and what i will
do is i will search for the first three
or four words in a part that i want to
highlight and then if you do that search
there's like a 99.99
chance that you will get to just the
right place in the book sometimes if
it's a special word i just type in one
word and it probably gets me to the
right place so i will just find it in
the online book and i will highlight it
and this feels like a very kind of
therapeutic activity to me it's quite
brain dead so
i'll just put some loud music on and
i'll just sit down in front of my
computer for anywhere between like 10
minutes to an hour or two hours
depending on the length of the book i i
will just manually highlight things on
my computer and then those will kind of
integrate with read-wise and go straight
into my notion as everything else so
this is one way that i do things another
way that i do things is using read-wise
and i haven't actually used this a lot
but you can just use read-wise on your
phone and kind of
lift the phone in front of your book and
it will kind of scan the book for you
and it will turn screen this is probably
worth trying but like i said because i
don't use physical books as a much um in
2021 i haven't been able to utilize this
feature as much the first way i can
definitely vote for i've done so many
books this way but the second one yeah
would definitely recommend trying next
is online articles these are usually
things i find on twitter or that ali
sends to me because i don't actually
read a lot of articles i prefer books a
lot more but sometimes there's some
really great ones out there and what i
like to do to them is
again depending on their length if it's
a really really short article what i
will do is i will just share this to my
notion and there's a great notion web
clipper if i am on my actual computer i
have the web clipper downloaded onto my
chrome and i will just click on it and
this whole file will then go on to my
notion and then i'll just copy and paste
the parts of it that i find interesting
and i want to highlight or what happens
most often is i'll just save it there
for later and sometimes maybe even two
years down the line or six months down
the line i might find the time that i
actually need it and i'll use it then or
if i'm on my phone you can do the exact
same thing on a mobile device where i'll
just share it to notion and it will be
saved onto this page where i have all
these different links and articles
together now the other thing that i will
do if it's a very long article in praise
of idealness comes to mind here 100
would recommend a great read what i do
in that case is that the whole article
is kind of like a book so it will need
processing of its own so in this case i
do not like sharing it to notion
immediately but i share it through insta
paper so insta paper is kind of like a
highlighting app so obviously i'm
mentioning quite a few apps in this um i
do tend to invest a lot of money in my
note-taking because it makes me really
happy but um through insta paper what i
will do is i'll kind of highlight on it
and it does the exact same thing it's
kind of like a kindle for pdfs and those
will integrate with my read wise and
they will just send it to my notion
automatically or you can kind of send
the highlights to your kindle if you
want to read it in your kindle and
export it that way but my favorite way
to do it is using insta paper if you
don't want to spend any sort of money um
and you want to read the article at that
time what i would do is using nursing
which is free so i would share the whole
article to notion or i would just copy
and paste the highlights of the article
that i would want to save if you are
reading it at that time lastly is
twitter this is a new one for me because
i used to think that twitter was just
the place for petty arguments and
although it really doesn't disappoint in
that department i find that it is a
goldmine of curated content i find
twitter threads to be absolutely
incredible i would definitely recommend
getting on the app just for that reason
alone so with twitter there are
different things that i will capture
some of the things will just be like
haha funny things that i want to send to
people at a more social hour than when
i'm usually browsing twitter so those
will just go straight into the in-app
bookmarks um and that's where i will put
most of the things that i like i'll just
save directly on twitter but also what i
will do is i will share them from my
phone directly to the links page on my
notion where they will be saved and then
depending on what they are if it's an
external article it will go to my insta
paper or if it's just the tweet itself
it will stay in my links in notion so
with the system everything has ended up
in two places one is my read wise notion
library and two is my lynx notion
library for read wise this is where i
collect things from all the articles
i've read all the kindle books i've read
all the apple books i've read
so all of the insta papers will just go
directly onto that read wise page and
then the second page is my links page
and this is my notion web clipper so
these are things that i found either on
my desktop or on my phone that are just
short and snappy there are links to
different things that i've seen
sometimes i'll find someone recommends a
webpage
that for a product that i might not buy
immediately or i'll see something that
i'll think oh this would be a great gift
for
my sister for her next birthday so i'll
just share this thing to my notion web
clipper and then i'll have a library of
mostly links there so these are the two
places where i can find absolutely
everything one last important thing that
i want to add to this video and that is
the cases where i don't take notes
there's this weird overlapping
conditions of things where they're
interesting but the notes are either too
much and i know i won't really need them
and it would be too much work for too
little effort and that's where i will
not take notes from a book i'm reading
in that case i love to use things like
short form now on the surface short form
looks like a book summaries page and
i mean i guess it is the thing is it
doesn't replace books the aim of the app
is not that you read those rather than
reading the book itself and usually the
most of the things that i read on short
firm i have read the book itself first
for example i really like the e-myth
revisited it's a very good business book
for someone who's completely clueless
when it comes to business like me but
because i don't find the topic that
interesting i'm not really taken to
making highlights on it so what i do
instead is i trust somewhere like short
form where i'll go and i know that all
the best highlights and all the best
summaries are already made after i've
read the book the great thing about the
e-myth revisited on short form for
example is that it's also curated the
main um and the most important exercises
there too so i can go through them in
the shortened version itself and i don't
have to reread the whole book again and
again but i really really don't enjoy
doing so what i love about short form is
that they're not trying to make you stop
reading the books itself because that
would be something that i don't think i
could align myself with ever but they
just try to make it easier to access the
great ideas in incredible books if
you're like me and you're trying to get
into things like business and health or
if you're interested in productivity
there are literally so many books on
short form that i would recommend they
get updated weekly and we can actually
even vote on which books get to go on
there so i want to thank short form so
much for sponsoring this video and
they've given us a free five-day trial
to kind of check out the books and see
what they offer so the next 100 visitors
to shortform.com elizabeth will be
receiving unlimited access for five days
and a discounted annual subscription but
yes this is how i have completely
removed any sort of anxiety when it
comes to reading and capturing and
saving and processing information
there's still other things i capture
like podcasts and youtube videos but
they're not technically things that i
read so i think i might do a separate
video on those please let me know if you
would be interested in something like
that if you made it so far and you're
probably interested in kind of
note-taking and that sort of thing i
have a whole video on how i set up my
second brain which might interest you
but otherwise we're all done here thank
you so much for spending this time with
me i hope you have a wonderful rest of
the day be kind to yourself and others
and don't believe everything you think
thanks bye